yeah but what about bruno i mean he's we
don't talk about bruno we don't talk
about bruno and kanto is all magic and
mystery from cut scenes and characters
to covet messing with the status quo
this movie endured a lot of changes to
the script and creation process in order
to get made let's take a look let's dig
a little deeper into what makes the
music of encanto sing a trope as old as
time
in one plot line of the movie due to
mirabelle's mistakes something bad
happened to mirabelle's mom julieta
i couldn't do it
and now my mom
is we have our theories as most of the
disney princesses are motherless for
whatever reason so we are really glad
they didn't go this route
such a huge corporation like disney
leaves so much room for improv stephanie
beatriz improvised a ton all throughout
encanto not just the comedy bits but the
darker things like the conversations
with abuela too one line that one
hundred percent came from her own brain
was in bruno's room after she was
abandoned by pico the toucan nope he
flew away immediately
but the improv king had to be actor
comedian john leguizamo who played bruno
improvising the entire rat telenovela
their love could never be
a little lesson from casita watch where
you pee
there's an after credit scene where
antonio's capybara named chipsy tries to
take a leak on casita but the home
strikes back this scene was cut because
the creators decided it wasn't the note
they wanted to end the movie on but
personally we think it's the perfect
finale what do you think
we don't talk about emo mo mo mo bruno's
name was oscar before it was bruno when
the team decided to change the name in
order to legally protect themselves
given there are a lot of oscar madrigals
in colombia they gave lin-manuel miranda
the options of arlo anko andre emo bruno
or marco he picked bruno and rolled with
it and came up with the opening of we
don't talk about bruno almost instantly
we don't talk about emo just doesn't hit
the same way we had to create this
really quirky offbeat guy
who was who had bad social skills
basically and he has to hide away
isabella wasn't always your cliche
disney princess gone rogue just a couple
drafts of the isabella included her as a
punk rocker and one where she runs away
with her city-slicking animal
urine-wearing boyfriend booboo we highly
recommend you check out the cut scene
called isabella goes into the woods it's
so weird we still struggle to believe
this was a genuine plot at one point
booboo marquez
are you all right
i am fine miami isabella could even
bring vegetables to life like elsa and
olaf at one point specifically potato
people we aren't sure if it was all
vegetables so there was a little family
of potato people living with her between
bubo and potatoes we're a little
surprised her character's journey became
what it did
is our only chance to be free
we could use a whole other song about
all of the cut characters so many
characters were cut or changed
drastically from one draft to the next a
cut character named zoe could
communicate with machines there were two
twins who gave off the auras of
compulsion and repulsion there was
originally a moody fire character named
fuega which we can see being the
inspiration for peppa peppa's power was
changed from indestructible to weather
controlling because she was too similar
to louisa
and controlling the weather used to be
julieta's power
in an earlier draft the default skin
camilo was hanging around in wasn't
actually his true form so when the magic
died he lost his power and nobody
recognized him which is super sad this
was eventually cut because it took too
much attention off of yerebel
yeah i like did the whole thing
so like it's extremely special to me the
show-stopping number got summarized in
half the time
the song all of you was originally going
to be seven minutes long it's already a
fantastical song that combines surface
pressure what else can i do and we don't
talk about bruno a very broadway thing
to do but originally it also contained
more of the villagers and abuela
offering some clarity on why she did
what she did singing i was so afraid of
losing what we've made focused on the
dark instead of letting in the light i
lost your father far too soon i couldn't
bear to lose you too the miracle is not
some magic we forgot the miracle is you
not some gift just you we don't need any
excuses abuela kidding but we feel like
her heart to heart at the river with
mirabelle was enough this cut is totally
understandable i thought we would have a
different life
i thought
i would be a different woman
stephanie beatriz was waiting on a
miracle much larger than mirabelle's she
was over nine months pregnant when she
recorded the song waiting on a miracle
and she had the baby just 48 hours later
in the booth she had to do whatever she
had to do to be able to get those high
notes out which generally included
putting her hands over her head and she
even did a bunch of squats
what can she say except you're welcome
for her audition stephanie beatrice
originally had to sing that fun catchy
tune from moana sung by dwayne the rock
johnson the best part was that somebody
animated it well let me say let me say
you're welcome
fight fight fight
you know what this was probably not an
entirely appropriate thing for a family
movie but
in an earlier version of the film
isabella and mirabelle actually got into
a physical fight and apparently
it was hilarious we're sad we missed it
but it's probably for the best
this budget isn't for belly button
piercings and kanto seriously had a
belly button budget dedicated solely to
having the one minor character's gut pop
on screen giving side characters belly
buttons is a big deal
they're rarely ever animated on minor
characters unless it's maybe a beach
scene but the crew totally found the
work worth it to give the donkey
delivery guy his gut
by the way that was his name in the
script for a while
oh and antonio good luck last gift
ceremony was a bummer while we're on the
topic of names the woman with the dead
fish her name was senora pes muerto
which translates to mrs deadfish we
guess naming minor characters based on
their minor roles makes a lot of sense
for keeping them all organized and it's
also much nicer than calling them
background number one and background
number two but in this instance maybe
they should have stuck with that
just act normal no one has to know
it takes a village to create a character
who's to say the voice actors are the
only ones acting animators are also
actors and during a time of covid their
reference videos were done in their
houses we appreciate the dude who went
to the extent of using his bed sheets as
skirt references the residuals must be
nice when you're trilingual angie sepeda
who plays julieta is the only actor to
voice her character in three different
languages
english spanish and italian i healed
your hand
with my love for my daughter the crew
was seriously racing against the clock
to finish in kanto they were working on
the movie basically up until the moment
it had its premiere they technically
wrapped production a month before its
release but they were still making minor
adjustments after that when we think of
the best apology songs we instantly
think taylor swift not lin-manuel
miranda miranda based the song surface
pressure on his sister it's his love
letter and his apology to her as she was
the eldest sister in the family and
definitely felt some of that pressure
miranda's mouth clicks he recorded for
the scratch track made it into surface
pressure too it's such a simple and nice
little touch we get the song called
surface pressure and it was about how
she's very cool on the surface and
there's nothing she can handle turns out
the manta rigal casita is full of
secrets it took some work for the team
to come up with what they wanted luisa's
room to look like they had a dull stone
room to represent her strength which
ended up lending itself to bruno's room
and it was set on a beach at one point
but the best idea was that she had a
secret room inside of her room that was
an amusement park to de-stress a bit we
kind of feel bad for mirabelle though
who didn't even get a single magic room
let alone two
while it's cool to know you can do voice
acting from home
the cast all had to record in their
homes while they got most of the
characters sounding the same we're
pretty sure we caught a couple lines
where isabella sounds like she's in a
different room if you weren't always
trying too hard you wouldn't be in the
way actually isa did you hear it or are
we paranoid now that we think about it
she could have just been leaning into
the mic before covid whenever possible
voice actors would do ensemble
recordings in an actual studio most of
them didn't even meet until the first
screening how crazy is that see myself
be a part of something so monumental
just an incredible feeling you know
reverse psychology choreography
choreography is usually done after the
scene layout is complete since the
choreographer was brought in before the
layout's completion it meant the dancers
had more influence over the shots of the
film because the method was so
successful we wonder if the industry
will follow in in kanto's footsteps from
now on disney comes with all the perks
stephanie beatriz worked with vocal
coach eric vitro he's incredible he's
really really gifted he's been the coach
to ariana grande camila cabello and sean
mendes to name a few
and kondo will forevermore hold a
special place in our hearts it's by far
one of disney's best films in a long
time and if you believe in magic believe
in this two years before stephanie
beatriz was even hired to voice the role
mirabelle's name was beatrice is that
not fate or what are there any other
movie-making secrets we should have
included in the video let us know in the
comments and thanks for joining us here
at the things